今日は次ショートスリーパーのように見えて実は1日9時間くらいは寝たいと心から
思っています肇社長です
ちなみに女が二人になってる時は決して僕は整形したわけではなくもともと僕は奥二重
パッと見一重なんだけども奥二重なのですが寝不足になるとなぜか2位になるんです
覚えた
てください皆さん寝るときにアイマスクつけますでしょうか
なかなか寝れない人がよく合いますくっつけると思うんですけどもなのでアイマスクを
着けると真っ暗なんですごいねやすいんですよね
でこのアイマスクなんですけども私は思ってしまった夜の中には眠りが深い人いますよ
ねそっとこれあなたもちょっとしたらね縁の深い人かもしれない中にはもう一回寝ると
前
で起きないような人間もおりましてこういう後輩ない今一人家に呼んでおりますね僕の
経験上あいつ場所で起きないんですよただいても起きないしてなんか結構大きな院で寝
てる間に何かしてもあんまり反応しない意識のないターゲットは言いますとそれずには
今回アイマスクをつけてネタバナンですけどもなんとなんとですね
こちら一時期話題になりましたねすまほぐ
一波スマホをやれとみられる vr のゴーグル
僕今会社のはまあ眠りが深い放って大きなもなんかぼーっとしてるんですよなんでアイ
マスク付けて寝ます
で寝てる間に僕こそに来ないマスクを外してにこの vr ゴーグルをつけてあげます
と
で起きないわけじゃないですかそのターゲットが起きて目を開けるとそこには
一休化が広がったねえねえ空間も多分
ぼーっとしてるんで現実だと思い込むんだと思うんです
ぼーっとしてるんで起きてもしばらく vr 世界が現実だと思い込むんですよまさに
sword art online ちょっとそういう音て大きいたらまずの仮想空間
にいるドッキリをやってみようと思いますかなぜか本当に分からない
カンのいい人だったら多分すぐ気づくと思うんですけど
存在してあげるやつは結構馬鹿なんで多分本当に vr につれ仮想世界が現実世界だ
と寝起きで思ってしまうのだと僕は思いますどれくらいのリアリティがあるかっていう
のもまた大事ですよね
実際にどんなも動画を見せるかという子たちです結構しっかりしてますねこうやって
いるターゲットを寝てる間に応じてあげるとさーああなにを見せてやろうかな
vr アプリダウンロードしましたちゃんと動作するから外を見てみましょう
おすげえこれやば宇宙だと思っちゃうアップすかちゃダメ
岩山にぶつかっちゃった多いわいてきにゃんだよなんか普通
きっとコースターみたいなやついいと思うんだよねつぎ360が9月入らのな奴がある
上を聞いてこれ声だろうなぁ
うわぁれてるからタグをうわぁ山を8青空が広がってんな
おきます富士急ずっとコースター完全に
高はこれまたこれ後ろの女の子のパンツ見えそうだなつみてよ
パンジーのパターパターレーサー済み
予想パンツ見えそうふわふわ強い山
かっハーグでマジでめっちゃ z コプター
[音楽]
う
もううおおおマジで怖いわずで強いこれはもっと
白山町またやウズ山田なく試合など6邪魔っていうめちゃくちゃ声ジェットコースター
の仮想空間に行ってもらいます相手にまずはターゲットしかに寝かせることが大事なの
でこの部屋でサケットと一緒に入れますでは os 皆さん入っよじゃあ
neo ネオぜでますかいやーをマジめちゃくちゃなーっ
えっようですよ寝るか
てねーん
[音楽]
おやすみなさい
ネザーん
えっ思うんだぞ
[音楽]
フォームだう
プランを練って4番が飛んでるんだぞはい
ぶりでした寝台
[音楽]
東京ディズニーシーじゃねーわやばいもう完全に寝てる
いやーわっ
数えはいやいやネイルなって思います9冊目てねーよ
スペディア多いを得た b
すごいねます
件さすがなああいうつんざい思っていたんですよ
さあもうちょっと手間さん
[音楽]
ん
断線にマクスです
[音楽]
うん
でございますか悩んでます
[音楽]
てますよ
うーん
しています
持った
tan
ねハイルーフ
すって
えっよこれはこちらへ by ジョブ
ふぅ
いいえ
えっ強度いっ
そうよどうだったやよい
入ってい
言わ者委はもう乗ってるうちには私だわー
バーン
ん
ああああああああ
[音楽]
ええええええ
[拍手]
あーうはぁあああああ白チノずう
わー
よだよ二頭を剃っ
出てこさん苦手ダイスん
おっ
ああああ怖いはこれパはし子ガッパ
ただけで寝て仲間が起きな人にこそ d 起きたボートして瞬間にリアルのゴーグル
つけさせて仮想世界に言うとどうなるかドッキリでした
あった
無理しほんとそれ